sie haben mit der biologin und
nobelpreisträgerin professor christiane
nüsslein-volhard über die geschlechter
vielfalt gesprochen und sie behauptet
alles unfug es gibt nur weiblich und
männlich und nichts diverse schauen wir
uns mal an was sie dort sagt bevor wir
beide weiter sprechen
viele geschlechter alles unfug behauptet
professor christiane nüsslein-volhard in
der aktuellen ausgabe der ema und sie
sollte es wissen denn sie ist ein
wissenschaftliches schwergewicht 1995
wurde die deutsche biologin mit dem
nobelpreis ausgezeichnet
und nun macht sie in einem interview
klare aussagen
es gibt menschen die wollen ihr
geschlecht ändern aber das können sie
gar nicht sie bleiben weiterhin xy oder
xx menschen behalten lebenslangen ihre
geschlechtszugehörigkeit aber sehen dass
eigentlich alle so also ich höchstens
drei geschlechter weil manche haben ja
irgendwie
erklären aber ich glaube entweder zwei
oder drei aber in manchen fans und ist
die bsh aber ja sonst halt nur um eine
frau
mann und frau und ländern finde ich
unmöglich
für mich reicht
na ja es kommt ganz drauf an also
biologisch gesehen sind gibt es mann und
frau aber geschlechts mäßig also
gibt es ja viele verschiedene formen
aber was ist wenn man sich anders fühlt
der wehrbeauftragte der bundesregierung
sven lehmann hatte eine eigene meinung
der ansicht zu sein dass es zwei
geschlechter gäbe ist unwissenschaftlich
es gibt viele geschlecht künftig sollen
alle jugendlichen ab 14 ihr geschlecht
daher selber bestimmen können
nobelpreisträgerin christiane nüsslein
volhard hält das für völlig unangebracht
das ist wahnsinn mit 14 sind ganz viele
mädchen der pubertät unglücklich der
gesetzgeber kann gar keine
geschlechtsumwandlung ermöglichen er
sagt nur diese frau darf ab jetzt
behaupten sie sei ein mann und umgekehrt
die biologischen grundlagen sind absolut
nichts zu ändern
[Musik]
bereits vor wenigen wochen hat die
absage eines vortrags über das
biologische geschlecht für aufregung
gesorgt als die biologie doktorand in
marie luise voll bricht an der humboldt
universität in berlin in der nacht der
wissenschaften einen vortrag zur
zweigeschlechtlichkeit halten will gibt
es proteste vor allem in den sozialen
medien stoßen die fronten aufeinander
die uni sagt den vortrag schließlich ab
die begründung sicherheitsbedenken die
proteste haben wirkung gezeigt wer heute
behauptet es gebe nur zwei geschlechter
muss mit gegenwind rechnen
ja froh ist dass also das interview das
sie geführt haben mit einer biologin
muss man dazu sagen aber es gibt ja auch
durchaus eine psychologische komponente
wie ist ihre ansicht
naja also um erstmal auf das zu kommen
was die frau ins land voller hat gesagt
hat ich bin natürlich auch der ansicht
mit ich glaube 99 der bevölkerung
das ist zwei biologische geschlechter
gibt darüber hinaus gibt es was die
junge frau da gerade so schlecht
erklären konnte er gibt es intersexuelle
menschen das sind menschen bei denen
aufgrund 1 der körperlichen abweichungen
die geschlechtsmerkmale von beiden
geschlechtern sich sozusagen ausbilden
da haben wir aber auch wieder nur die
beiden geschlechter und kein drittes
oder vier oder fünf oder 28 so was es
natürlich gibt und was finde ich
verwechseln dürfen ist es gibt natürlich
unendlich viele soziale geschlechter
also es gibt unendlich viele
möglichkeiten mit diesem biologischen
geschlecht was zu machen also das heißt
eine frau kann barbie sein sie kann aber
auch kfz mechanikerin sein um jetzt mal
im café zu sprechen so und wir
feministin sagen eben wunderbar liebe
frauen und natürlich auch liebe männer
guckt einfach welche frau welcher man
ihm sein wollte
warum sagt jetzt herr lehmann es gibt so
viele geschlechter weil er dieses
narrativ von diesem es gibt so viele
geschlechter und jeder kann sich
sozusagen science aussuchen benutzt um
das sogenannte selbstbestimmung gesetz
durchzubringen das also demnächst
vorschlagen und und dann auch irgendwann
in kraft treten soll und
dieses gesetz sagt jeder mensch soll
einmal im jahr auf dem standesamt sein
geschlecht ändern können also das heißt
ich könnte dann zum standesamt gehen und
sagen ich habe war bisher standhalten
aber ab morgen bin ich daniel und das
muss akzeptiert werden das darf auch
nicht hinterfragt werden und da sagen
wir moment mal da haben wir ein problem
mal unterm strich werden folgen am
anfang der sendung ich weiß nicht ob es
da schon mitbekommen haben auch über die
ravensburg ravensburger verlag
gesprochen und die rennerei und wog und
indianer soll man nicht mehr sagen
hier haben wir
die geschlechterdebatte über
transsexualität machen wir uns das leben
unnötig schwer oder müssen wir auf all
die ja doch es sind minderheiten belange
eingehen auch als insel halten natürlich
ich möchte ganz klar sagen wir sind
selbstverständlich und das ist die form
nüßlein fordert auch dafür dass menschen
die wirklich therapeutisch abgeklärt
transsexuell sind selbstverständlich in
ihrem wunsch zu schlecht leben können
nur sagen wir eben es gibt wenn wir
diese selbstbestimmung gesetz hätten
zwei probleme das ein problem ist wir
haben in den letzten jahren einen
unglaublichen anstieg von jugendlichen
die von sich denken und behaupten sie
seien nicht binär oder transsexuell oder
sonst irgendwas
und es liegt auf der hand zehnmal so
viele mädchen wie jungen tun das ist
liegt auf der hand dass wir da es nur
mit einer abweichung mit einem riesigen
unbehagen der geschlechter rolle zu tun
haben und was wir da tun müssten finde
ich ist diesen mädchen aber auch den
jungs zu sagen ihr könnt auch wenn ihr
also bei den mädchen fußball spielt wenn
ihr kurze haare habt wenn ihr nicht in
die form passt wenn ihr nicht in das
rein passen was ihr bei den influenza in
vorgelebt kriegt seid ihr trotzdem
richtige mädchen so und was aber
passiert ist dass ihnen suggeriert wird
du passt nicht ins schema dann bist du
wohl trans und das riesenproblem dass
wir dann haben ist dass als nächstes und
das haben wir in deutschland schon
diese kinder sehr früh mit pubertiert
blockern behandelt werden deren
spätfolgen überhaupt nicht erforscht
sind dass sie ab 16 schon mit hormonen
behandelt werden dürfen die ebenfalls
ihre version folgen haben und da sagen
wir eben entschuldigung ist kann nicht
sein dass ohne das gar therapeutisch
ganz genau geguckt wird diese
jugendlichen denen sozusagen
auf dem silbertablett präsentiert wird
für alle deine probleme die du in der
pubertät hast gibt es die lösung du bist
dran das problem nummer eins problem
nummer zwei ist wenn sich jedermann
einfach so zur frau erklären kann
dann hat das auswirkungen auf geschützte
frauen räume sie haben dann also zum
beispiel einen ich sag jetzt mal 1 90
meter großen biologischen mann der in
einer frauen dusche sich aufhält mit
seinem noch vorhandenen
geschlechtsorgane wie wirkt das auf
kleine mädchen wie wirkt es auf frauen
die vielleicht mal sexuelle gewalt
erfahren haben
es haben sich in den letzten tagen auch
schon juristen zu wort gemeldet die mit
sexualstraftätern arbeiten und die sagen
das eröffnet sozusagen eine unglaubliche
möglichkeit des missbrauchs
naja eine frau die hat natürlich das
nutzen kann um zu sagen ich erkläre mich
jetzt zur frau das sind die probleme die
wir haben also wir reden nicht nur über
ein bisschen ländern oder so sondern wir
reden hier von jugendlichen die unter
und in ihre versieben körperliche
schäden davontragen
großes problem gut dass die darauf
hingewiesen haben vielen dank frau lois
[Musik]